[Music]
hey
hey hey hey come on
question bertie it's very simple
i drink a real margarita
and a bunch of viewers tweeted questions
of me and tarek and we're gonna answer
some of them right now
tarek are you ready i am ready nico
meeker
asked what's your dream vacation oh
great question great question what is
your dream vacation amber i just like to
be near the blue blue water
now i don't want to touch the water and
i don't i don't want to be in there i
don't know
what animals are in there i don't care
for that but i want to be near it and i
want to touch the sand
and i want to feel too hot i want to be
close to passing out constantly
so you want to be close to passing out
you want to be by the blue water but not
in the blue wall
that's right okay you want it to be too
hot yeah but you won't be comfortable
enough
no no i want to be on fire you want to
be on fire yeah but you don't want to
touch the water that's right
okay so hey it's going to be short
vacation that is hell
oh yay i'm on my way there
tarik what's your dream vacation um
i would like to solve a murder on a
train going across europe
tarik if you don't shut up yes
yes derek i can't even tell if you're
joking
i'm not
[Laughter]
or am i oh my gosh
a big bad beast
asked who was your favorite my little
pony
in the 80s in the 80s
i have several um okay so
when i was young i had 50 my little
ponies whoa
a lot of them were like little like my
little pony things but i would
line them all up and be like ah mine i'm
rich um
and uh which i was not um
so i think my first my little pony was
blue
bell these are old school my little
ponies you don't even know nothing about
this this ain't no pinkie pie [ __ ] this
is old school
blue bale bluebell i ended up giving to
my brother my brother
cut all of his hair off to make me mad
um also
then one day i found posie
in the front lawn because some kid had
dropped her
and like it was all bitten up by a dog
but i didn't care i love posey
then um you know i did like yum yum
i liked um baby apple dumpling there was
the
mom that was apple uh
mommy apple dumpling and then their dad
back when they had boy
my little ponies which blew my mind and
it was uh he had trees on his butt
and then the baby had apple trees oh
that was so cute
and then also the best milo pony
was um princess tiffany
i think her name was princess tiffany
anyway she was white and she was sparkly
and some of her hair was hair but some
of her hair was like little bits of um
like
like like foil gold like streamers you
know
it was really really beautiful because
no i just love how sparkly she was and
like she had a big jewel on her butt
okay
good elo asked what was your favorite
show slash cartoon when you were a kid i
mean
tarik take it away i mean uh
i mean when i was a kid i mean have you
seen me
i'm still four uh
ooh i mean i guess when i was a kid kid
there was a cartoon called uh
silverhawks
um yeah partly metal partly real
um it had like a season yeah come on
it was like it was the copper kid
partly metal partly real silver
i can't hit that note it goes high but
silver
and it was like it was basically it made
no sense
it was people in space who were bionic
birds and would fight crime
in space and i loved it
and they had lasers but the laces were
in their elbow
but and they you have to line up the
elbow
what it made no sense but they were
partly metal and partly real
and i was like oh that's dope it was
between that and bionic six
about a multiracial family no don't
leave
about a multi-racial family uh of people
who are bionic
and there was iq
there was a karate kid that's all the
time we have
uh this was great the mother and father
were loosely based on the six million
dollar man in the bionic woman
there was a black guy who was really big
and smart named iq i wanted to be iq
there was a villain called gloves that
sounds good yeah he wore a glove
oh did he yeah it was buzz saw oh
he never had a bus auto but he he taught
like he was revving up an engine
oh yeah that's fun too